an unexpected Source has given me a
little bit of information about Stargate
and what we can expect and when we can
expect Stargate to return to our screens
and I've got to say this might not
necessarily be good news it might
actually be the first time we've heard
rumors
the Stargate might not happen at all
Welcome to psycheck our Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
apologies for this quick um video in a
car park in Telford where I live but I
got this news and I just wanted to share
with you as quickly as possible so if
you are a regular side tracker then
you'll know that I speak to a few
sources that I have that work in and
around MGM and Amazon
now these people have spoken to me
um regularly about Stargate coming back
and the very confusing situation between
MGM and Amazon right now
so here's the update
apparently early this week there was a
big marketing meeting one of the people
I speak to was privy to what happened in
that meeting
the general discussion was about Amazon
and mgm's uh marketing campaign that was
planned for when Amazon bought MGM the
idea being always that they would have
three big projects announced really
quickly to give a boost to Amazon's
image now their image is very important
and Amazon in the last couple of months
particularly has had a bit of a kick in
the stories about Lord of the Rings for
example have not been good
the Fallout from Wheel of Time and
things like this have not been good so
they always hoped to use something like
Stargate project as a big announcement
something to have some positive news
to be honest
say he'll have Amazon to MGM itself was
not particularly well handled and not
particularly well it wasn't popular in
social media
so
this plan of having three big projects
um a movie something from the IP
Stargate and bond
this meeting the marketing was basically
to try and figure out what the hell went
wrong
for one Bond I've always been told from
day one that Bond would be first and
then Stargate would follow and the
Amazon considered Stargate to be the
sleeping giant of sci-fi they wanted to
be their big Sci-Fi show the equivalent
to what Paramount has with Star Trek
but Bond
has been a cock-up from beginning to end
apparently MGM seriously had renish on
page lined up to be a new James Bond it
was going to be a young exciting pre-007
James Bond
but James but this fella John Rennie
page when he's on page has signed up to
be the saint now MGM didn't seem to have
a problem with that but Amazon came in
and went no this is our Flagship project
we cannot have the actor doing a project
like the saint that is so similar so now
renish on page cannot be the new James
Bond that has thrown everything into
absolute bloody turmoil
so James Bond no clue it's going to be
probably a couple of years till we know
what the hell's going on with that so
that's thrown Stargate into an element
of problem
um because now we don't know what's
going on with that either
the problem is basically the MGM had
were ready to green eye Stargate but the
Amazon voices never liked it so they
come in and we're not doing that we
don't like this we've told you enough we
don't particularly like this story we're
not doing it so they've started again
now Mark Fergus and Hawk Osby are being
lined up to
develop a new Stargate show I'm being
told that a little bit more now that
actually not only they're being asked to
develop a show but they're actually
being able to look at the entire
Stargate Universe as a whole and develop
something that could be turned into not
just one show but a couple of different
shows very much like Alex kurtman did
with Star Trek it seems to me
so we're looking at
a whole new universe in a way of
Stargate looking more like again not a
hard reboot but like what Star Trek had
this sort of like semi-hard reboot which
does sound dirty but it's going to be
like a hybrid but somewhere between a
soft and hard reboot now I don't know if
I particularly love that idea but it's
what we're going to be stuck with so
let's just well I think it's just what
we're going to go with so in this
marketing meeting this was discussed it
was discussed about how well why don't
we just announce Stargate now
we have these guys going in development
and the answer from some Amazon
executive who seems to be a bit nameless
was we don't know if we're going to be
doing that
so they're going into development
they're going to come back with
something to Amazon and then they're
going to decide whether they want to
push forward or not the marketing people
would love to announce this now they
would love to announce something there's
anything from MGM to have that big new
story
Amazon won't let them do Stargate
because they're not sure they're even
going to do Stargate
that was the way it came across to me
from this Source now they definitely
seem to be wanting to push forwards with
it and they definitely seem to want to
do Stargate
but they're not sure they're going to
so I came back and I asked my sister
what do you mean by this what do you
mean that they they might not and this
is basically Amazon will not green
lighter project unless they're confident
of its success they are not going to
waste loads of more money on a TV show
that's going to flop this is going to be
the big franchise and they wanted to
succeed and if they're not confident is
going to they just won't do it
that is the first time I really have
heard that there might be a serious
possibility of them not being a Stargate
this marketing meeting really has thrown
my confidence levels down a little bit I
mean I was like 95 sure we were going to
get the star getting out this year
now I'm like
75 percent
um and dropping I'm I'm not 100
confident we're going to get anything
announce this year
um according to my source he reckons
he's 50 50 on whether we'll get
something announced this year he's a bit
more confident we'll get something
announced in the tax year which would be
by next April
um but I'm not I'm not as confident I
like that these guys Mark Fergus and
Hawk Hospital are developing something
that shows and Amazon has a confidence
and they want to do something
but at the same time this answer over
why the marketing people saying why
don't we just announce it now we're
going to do it and the answer they're
told is well we might not so you can't
announce anything
that's depressing
now please get into the comments don't
shoot the messenger it's not my fault
this is just what I'm told and
you know I I will share it with you guys
because I'm told it but
um it's not my fault so if anybody wants
to get in the comments and call me a
liar or whatever else please don't
bother
um I don't read them anyway but anyway
so
but that's one thing I would love for
you guys to get a comments go and tell
me what you think of this do you is your
confidence shaking a little bit because
I got to tell you mine is
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit the Bell notification
it really helps us out and if you enjoy
the content please don't forget to
consider hitting the join button that
really helps us out
as always guys please stay safe I'll see
you next time
[Music]